obviously one of the key components of
the black widow character is this
enigmatic pass which is still affecting
and defining her but it seems at the end
of this movie issues perhaps a lot more
receptive to maybe people known a bit
more on that that entails so would you
as an actress be interested in going
there and exploring that and realize a
little film or do you think perhaps some
things about left undefined and it got
the character of some very intriguing
mystery um well you'll get more of
widows backstory in in Avengers 2 also
really yeah and and I think her
backstory is I mean she has a rich rich
past as you just you know already
described she's she definitely comes
from a really dark past um you know I
think she's kind of had to be sort of
she's had to sort of D sensitize or
dehumanize in a way to be able to do and
see some of the things that she's you
know I'm seen and participated in
willingly and they probably most people
that have that kind of job um
description you know a mercenary they do
um but I think she's just sort of now
grappling with the fact that she may be
experiencing some trauma from that or at
least that she has feelings about the
things that that she's might maybe she
doesn't sleep so well at night and and
you know it's just sort of hitting her
now that she's kind of been you know
acting as a sort of you know gun for
hire and you know that in doing that
she's never really made any active
choices and that kind of it's sort of
like the rug has been she's kind of
pulled from under her feet so I think
more interestingly what would probably
be to discover her you know to follow
the progression of that story and you
know bring her back home or see where
that see where that kind of leads to but
of course you know
that's all in my imaginary next
installment you know none of that's
really been you know we've thrown the
ball around a little bit but um nothing
is in the works right now for that
you